[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another episode
of Harry Potter theory in this video
we'll be addressing a very common and
major question that we seen floating
around and that question is of course
the title of the video
how does Harry's expel the Armus beat
Voldemort unblockable
Avada Kedavra let's start with chapter
36 of the Deathly Hallows where there is
a descriptive passage that depicts the
powerful clash of magic between Harry
and Voldemort
Avada Kedavra expelliarmus the bang was
like a cannon blast and the golden
flames that erupted between them at the
dead center of the circle they had been
treading marked the point where the
spells collided Harry saw Voldemort
scream jet meet his own spell they saw
the Elder Wand fly high dark against the
sunrise spinning across the enchanted
ceiling like the head of Nagini
spinning through the air towards the
master it would not kill who had come to
take full possession of it at last Harry
with the unerring skill of the seeker
caught the wand in his free hand as
Voldemort fell backwards arms played the
slip pupils of the scout eyes rolling
upwards Tom Riddle hit the floor with a
mundane finality his body feeble and
shrunken the white hands empty the
snake-like face vacant and unknowing
Voldemort was dead killed by his own
rebounding curse and Harry stood with
two ones in his hand staring down at his
enemies shell what the passage above
effectively depicts is Harry's expel
Yama's besting Voldemort Avada Kedavra
but how isn't that impossible isn't it
undeflected
to begin answering that question we
first need to look at the context of the
passage more closely in their clash of
magic Harry - Psalms for the Mort who is
at the time in possession of the Elder
Wand they saw the Elder Wand fly high
spinning through the air towards the
master it would not kill who had come to
take full possession of it at last this
passage explains that because Harry is
the more deserving and rightful owner of
the Elder Wand that its power cannot be
effectively used against him in chapter
24 of the same book Harry talks to
Oliver
and the following passage explains the
importance of the relationship between
the wand and the caster a person can
still use a wand that hasn't chosen them
though ask Harry oh yes if you are any
wizard at all you will be able to
channel your magic through almost any
instrument the best results however must
always come where there is the strongest
affinity between wizard and wand
these connections are complex an initial
attraction and then a mutual quest for
experience the one learning from the
wizard the wizard from the wand what
this explains is that there is more to
being powerful than just a powerful
wizard utilizing a powerful wand ie
Voldemort and the Elder Wand the
relationship between the two is equally
as important as the inherent power of
each and a failure to establish this
almost symbiotic relationship will
result in a shortfall of magical
capabilities and the eventual failure of
the ones mastery bottom all was never
the true holder of the Elder Wand
nor was he able to form any sort of
relationship with it which resulted in
his inability to master it this meant
that his power was stunted and in an
interesting turn of events he was
perhaps even less powerful than he would
have been with his regular wand Harry
was the true master of the wand which
meant that it would not kill him and
Voldemort being the unlawful owner of
the wand could not produce a level of
power that was enough to kill Harry
killing hers or not
and while the Elder Wand is one of the
main reasons for Harry defeating
Voldemort I think that it would be silly
to overlook the elephant in the broom
which is the fact that Voldemort used
Harry's blood to rebuild his body this
blood is of course the same blood that
belonged to Lily Harry's mother because
Voldemort uses Harry's blood to rebuild
himself a part of Harry and Lily lived
inside of him Voldemort believed that
this would allow him to successfully
attack Harry while simultaneously being
shielded by Lily's sacrificial
protection however this sort of
backfired as in doing so he actually
unintentionally rendered Harry the only
person capable of killing him
Voldemort was no longer a powerful being
in his own right in fact now existed as
a sort of a Horcrux for Harry as long as
the Voldemort lives
Harry could not die when Voldemort
attacked Harry in their final standoff
all that he killed mrs. own Horcrux and
the part of his soul that lived inside
of Harry this brings us back to the
Elder Wand as when the one recognized
that how it was in fact the true source
of Voldemort's power it saw Baltimore as
nothing more than protection for Harry
the ones true owner and with that being
said that concludes the video even some
diehard Harry Potter fans might not know
all of the ins and outs of this answer
so I hope you learned something until
next time
you're a wizard Harry
[Music]